your personality creates your personal
reality that's it and your personality
is made up of how you think how you act
and how you feel so the present
personality who's listening to this
podcast has created the present personal
reality called their life which means
that if you want to change your life you
want to create a new personal reality
you're gonna have to change your
personality you're gonna have to change
because nothing changes in your life
until you change so what is the
understanding of change that we've spent
over 10 years studying a way to explain
what change is because if you think
sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before you're
in trouble because the same thoughts
will lead to the same choices the same
choices will lead to the same behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences and the same experiences
produce those very same emotions and
those same emotions influence our same
thoughts and our biology everything
stays the same because we're the same I
gotta change my personality while this
concept of metacognition you know the
seed of our conscience our frontal lobe
allows us to think think about what
we're thinking about to notice how we're
behaving and to become aware of how
we're feeling and the repetition of
thinking acting and feeling in the same
way causes our brain to become hardwired
into very specific throat patterns right
so the moment we become conscious of
those thoughts the moment we become
aware of those behaviors the moments we
notice those feelings we're no longer
the program in fact part of the
Consciousness observing the program and
that's the first step to change need
motivation watch the top 10 We Believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Joe dispenza and my take on his top 10
was a success enjoy
rule number two be present look people
can create all kinds of wealth and they
can create all kinds of abundance they
can have the cars the homes and
everything but if they can't be present
right to enjoy them I've sat with
billionaires and they've looked me in
the eye and said we're all miserable
same here we're all miserable and and
and and and and and so then at what
point do you have to wait uh to change
does it have to be that lowest point or
or or can you learn and change in a
state of joy and inspiration instead of
instead of pain and suffering and that
that becomes the art right so then
to change then is to be greater than the
habituations the drives and the emotions
that have been conditioned in the body
to change is to be greater than the
conditions in our environment that every
person every object everything in our
life has a neurological Network
associated with them they're knowns
because we've experienced them and we
have an emotion associated with them so
you if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future you're left with
the memories of the past and you see
your ex and you're going to see your ex
through the memory of your past
neurologically and it's going to elicit
an emotional response and you're
thinking and feeling equal to your
environment your life's not going to
change so then the next question is how
could I overcome that condition that
with my ex can I actually forgive could
I actually open my heart can I actually
the reason we do this is because the
stronger the emotion we feel towards
someone or something in our life the
more we pay attention to them and where
we place our attention is where we place
our energy and so then we're giving our
power away to that person or
circumstance that's vital life force you
could use to change the person who's
sitting in the meditation
and they want to quit this is they're
thinking they're doing their meditation
wrong I want to tell you you're doing it
right that's the defining moment right
and you lower the volume to that emotion
I guarantee you'll take your attention
off that person and sooner or later when
the body finally settles down and you
get Beyond it you're going to take your
power back and that's building your own
electromagnetic field now you have
energy to heal now you have energy great
we've measured this now you have energy
for for creation rule number three
practice mental rehearsal we don't see
things how they are we see things how we
are and so the I don't like to use the
word visualization because I think it's
been
okay has been overused I like to use the
word mental rehearsal I don't care if
you're a virtuoso uh musician
I don't care if you are a performer or
an actor I don't care if you're a dancer
or an athlete everybody does this who's
engaged in getting better at whatever
they do they will rehearse a course now
or the re rehearse the ACT enough times
that the once they can concept the whole
thing to its completion
and they get out of that think box then
the think box is so important because we
have to
review our act we have to repeat it
enough times and the act of mental
rehearsal really installs the
neurological Hardware in your brain it
primes the brain free so you have
circuits to use now mental rehearsal
also changes the body you can take a
group of men and have them imagine or
rehearse doing bicep curls
for an hour a day for two weeks and add
an emotional component called stronger
harder more intense and for one hour
they practice in their mind doing those
those curls at the end of two weeks
there's a 13.5 increase in muscle
strength they never lifted a weight
their bodies changing by thought alone
so the person who's priming their brain
and body through rehearsal
when they get in their play box there's
no thinking they're just doing there's
just the act in fact the thought of what
they're doing becomes the experience
they get lost in the act and they're
analytical facilities their analytical
mind is out of the way and they can they
can sustain a state where nothing in
their environment is going to move them
from the state they're in the feeling of
what it would feel like to play well and
they hold on to that feeling and when
the conditions get tense they actually
do something different they
self-regulate and they actually crave
this moment of performance to be able to
produce an outcome and so there's no
mysticism to this it's just what people
do when they get really into something
is that we rehearse all the time so when
people understand if you take a group of
people that never played the piano
before and you teach them one-handed
scales them chords and they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you do a
brain scan and before and after they'll
grow circuits on the opposite side of
the brain no magic there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections you get your body involved
you get some instruction you have an
experience experience enriches the
circuits repeated over and over again
fire and wire and pay attention and stay
present you'll assemble new neurological
circuitry
take another group of people have them
close their eyes and actually have them
mentally rehearse playing the scales and
chords for two hours a day for five days
scan their brain before and after in the
end of five days their brain will look
like they've been playing the piano for
five days but they never lifted a finger
the brain literally changed through the
rehearsal okay so now take the person
and put them in front of a piano never
played the piano before and they could
actually play those scales and chords
like the people who are actually
physically demonstrating it so what does
that have to do for the single mother of
three children what does that have to do
with the person
who's trying to heal a health condition
it's not enough to just have a good
meditation and get up and spend the rest
of your day reacting and responding to
the conditions in your life that's one
hour of living or conditioning your body
and brain into the future against 15
hours of you and responding emotionally
from your past so we got to rehearse
okay how am I going to be in this
situation how am I going to change
what would love do today what would
greatness look like it's the it's those
frontal lobe questions that actually
begins to install the circuitry and we
all do it naturally the only time we
don't do it is when we're living in
stress and we're living in survival why
because it's not a time to create it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
go inward it's not and not a time to
Dream It's a time to run fight and hide
and if you're spending the majority of
your time in the arousal of those stress
hormones
than most people then their senses
become heightened they narrow their
focus and now they're engaged in doing
anything they can relying on something
outside of them to take away that
feeling so if people begin to understand
that they actually can change and
there's a they understand a formula to
do it and they practice that formula and
they rehearse it both by mentally
rehearsing it and actually participating
in it the effects should be in the
experiment that something should change
either in your body or in your life and
that's why we do it so when you see the
changes or the synchronicities or the
coincidences or the opportunities
starting to show up in your life you're
going to pay attention to what you did
and you're going to do it again and many
people who have chronic health
conditions that just get Beyond those
thoughts and those habits and those
emotions that keep them as that same
personality and begin to think act and
feel differently
notice dramatic changes in their in
their health and in their biology and we
have the data to suggest that people who
do this for seven days their body looks
like genetically and biologically
they're in a different life their body
is no longer responding in the same way
and they're no longer victims to their
environment because they can
self-regulate there tends to be a
greater resistance
uh to anything in their environment even
on a microscopic level rule number four
become truly conscious everybody has
done this
at some point in their life right where
they have to catch the thought
they have to catch how they speak the
ACT they have to notice oh this is that
weird feeling again I'm not going to
just stay in this feeling can I change
it right so then if you remind yourself
every single day of who you no longer
want to be before you start your day
become conscious of your unconscious
self so conscious that you don't don't
go unconscious in your waking day the
next fundamental question is if your
personality creates your personal
reality
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and with attention with
presence and intention energy
begin to Fire and wire that thought if
you can fire and wire that thought you
start installing the neurological
Hardware in your brain keep doing it and
start acting acting like a software
program it becomes more automatic that's
the new voice in your head that says you
can it's possible or whatever and then
how are you going to behave in the zoom
meeting how are you going to behave with
your children how are you going to
behave with your ex how are you going to
be today when you open your eyes now
here's the cool part and you know this
the act of closing your eyes and
mentally rehearsing
who you're going to be planning your
actions in the day
mental rehearsal
shows that you could actually install
the neurological Hardware in your brain
to look like you already did it or it
already happened now the brain is no
longer a record of the past it now
becomes a map to the Future okay we've
all rehearsed something in our life and
our minds over and over again keep doing
it keep rehearsing it keep reviewing it
and it'll start to become more automatic
and you could actually program a person
then to behave as a happy person no
magic there you installed the circuits
now here's the hardest part
can you teach your body emotionally
what that future would feel like before
it happens in other words don't wait for
your healing to feel gratitude don't
wait for your new relationship to feel
love don't wait for the mystical moment
to feel awe that's kind of the old model
of reality of cause and effect let's
wait for something out there to happen
to take away this emptiness this guilt
this lack the suffering whatever what if
I could condition my body emotionally
into the future so then we started
studying not only brain coherence but we
started studying heart coherence could a
person trade resentment and watch their
heart beat in a really irregular fashion
to a more coherent fashion where when
they're feeling gratitude when they're
feeling inspiration when they're feeling
love could they practice that enough
times so much so
they can condition their body into the
emotion of the future now here's the
cool part about that
our research shows you could absolutely
do that and do it so well that you feel
like the future that you're in wanting
to experience has already happened and
when it feels like it's already happened
you feel less separate from it which
means you're no longer looking for it
why would you look for it if you feel
like it's already happened now
to become familiar with the old self and
then fire and wire and condition the
body emotionally and chemically and
become familiar with the new self if
you're truly in the experiment of life
and I truly change my personality
there should be some evidence in my
world that there's been some change
either in my body and in my life in some
way and literally
their biology changes their their their
immune system changes they're we've
we've isolated thousands of metabolites
that show that that there's a
flourishing going on in the body the
body's responding it's believing
emotionally that it's living in a
different environment that's that's the
key also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five create heart
coherence can I teach my body
emotionally
what my future will feel like before it
happens now this is really important
because there's a pandemic going on in
the world that has nothing to do with a
virus that has everything to do with
people's attention span and learning
people need a rush of dopamine in order
to catch their attention or a rush of
adrenaline to learn and so that they're
they're dependent on their outer
environment to regulate their emotional
state now this is different now now I'm
going to say to you
get in that beautiful heart of yours and
I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can't feel
it because it hasn't happened yet yeah
that's the conditioning that's the
hypnosis
so then when you teach Purple People how
to create hard coherence and
self-regulate and it makes sense then
with a coherent brain they can hold the
image of their future they can actually
then rehearse who they're going to be
they can bring up the emotions of their
future now here's the cool part awesome
if they can feel their gratitude before
their healing their Healing Begins
if they feel their abundance or their
worthiness
before they have their wealth it will
start generating abundance if they start
being in love with themselves and being
in love with life they'll create an
equal That's the Law if they're in awe
of life or an awe of the moment they're
going to have a mystical experience if
they're empowered they're going to start
stepping towards their success success
so then when we wait for the outer World
to Change our internal State that's a
conditioning process because some people
will live in lack and separation their
entire life because they're not creating
anything when this happens then I'll
feel happy that's the illusion of
three-dimensional reality that's cause
and effect but feeling the emotion ahead
of the experience is causing an effect
so the heart when it's coherent tends to
produce
an external magnetic field that's up to
three meters wide now you've got a Wi-Fi
signal now when you have a coherent
brain the brain could actually lay the
information
on that signal and the thought of your
wealth or your health can be carried on
the frequency of that heart emotion
emotions are the end product of an
experience right
epigenetics says it's the environment
that signals the gene if the environment
signals the Gene and the end product of
an experience in the environment is an
emotion a person's signaling genes ahead
of the environment and now they're
biologically
believing behaving and actually becoming
that person so if the person sustains
that Satan State and we look at novice
meditators that come for a week
and ninety percent of them and and the
metabolites not just a few the majority
of the metabolites and novice meditators
suggest that their bodies in a different
life rule number six alter your
lifestyle chronic
diseases require a lifestyle change and
and change is an interesting concept so
the hardest part about change
is not making the same Choice as you did
the day before and the moment you decide
to make a different Choice get ready
because you're going to feel
uncomfortable it's going to feel
unfamiliar there's going to be some
uncertainty you're not going to be in
the known you're stepping out into the
unknown you're doing something
differently in the body which has been
conditioned to be the mind the servant
is now the master
so the body loves The Familiar known it
loves the same suffering it loves the
same pain it loves the same unworthiness
it's been conditioned that way for years
on end it really is running the show so
the moment you step out into the unknown
the body goes wait a second I'd rather
feel guilty than this feeling of the
unknown because I can't predict my
future so the body starts influencing
the mind and we start to hear this
chatter in our head that says Rock and
start tomorrow you know and tomorrow's a
better day you really don't feel like it
today why don't you just have one piece
of cake you're a loser it's your parents
fault it's your ex's fault it's your
culture's fault whatever it is and if we
accept believe and surrender to that
thought as if it's the truth that's an
old circuit in the brain that thought
will lead to the same Choice which will
lead to the same behavior which will
create the same experience but produce
the same feeling or emotion the person
says well this feels right to me no no
no no that feels familiar crossing the
river of change
going from the old self to the new self
there is a neurological a biological or
hormonal genetic death of the old self
there's pruning going on there's there's
inhibition going on where we're no
longer releasing the same stress
hormones that give us the arousal and so
if there's three types of stress
physical chemical and emotional physical
stress being trauma injuries accidents
Falls chemical stress you know viruses
bacteria pesticides pollutants toxins
hangovers whatever emotional stress
that's the big one that's a family
tragedies second mortgages single
parenting 401ks whatever it is it tends
to be then that the difficult one to
manage really is our emotional stress so
if you can help people to get more
physically balanced more chemically
balanced and to become more emotionally
balanced than the effects of their
personal change will be expedited yeah
and there'll be a longer duration so the
person sees you for six months they to
start a great program they start making
the right choices and they start feeling
better and then once they make the wrong
choice then it's a downward spiral back
to the old unconscious habits and
emotional conditions they feel unworthy
again and they return back to your
clinic or they return back to your
consultation and they come back with the
same exact conditions and The Simple
Solution is yeah because you return back
to the same personality and you're
feeling the same emotions and your
body's back to believing it's in the
same environmental condition so if your
personality
creates your personal reality and I
believe that and your personality is
made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel then the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life not
your ex not your parents not your boss
you create your life so it makes sense
then if you wanted to create a new
personal reality you'd have to change
your personality in other words if you
want to change your life you have to
change and nothing changes in your life
until you change so then this first step
and change then
95 of who we are as a set of unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions then the
first step is to become conscious of
your unconscious thoughts become so
aware of how you behave do you complain
do you blame do you make excuses you
judge do you are you aggressive and then
look at the emotions what is this
emotion I'm feeling wow this is guilt
this is sadness this is victimization
this is unhappiness name it so now
you're so conscious of it that you don't
go unconscious and return back to the
same self and how many times
do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
rule number seven find perfect moments
never try to reason with your children
they're emotional
because no new information can enter the
nervous system that isn't equal to the
emotion they're experiencing
do you want to be reasoned with when
you're emotional do you want to be left
alone
you want a few minutes yes now if
there's an injury if there's danger of
course you have to step in if there's
chemical needs of course you have to you
know take care of that but for the most
part with my children I allowed them
to have their moment
but what any whenever they had their
moment I would stop
whatever I was doing and I would turn
and look at them
and I would watch them I wanted them to
know that I was observing them never
said anything to them unless they asked
and when the emotions wore off I would
say to them
at the end of the day I'd get in bed
with them and I'd say
it's a tough day for me today
and I would share with them what I was
working on as if they were my best
friend or an adult I didn't hold back at
all with them
and I would do that
to create the space of safety where they
could start expressing
what they knew that I observed about
them
in the most objective way
self-reflective way
and then they would say oh yeah you know
I lost my temper with Paris you know her
friend and I said I know I saw you
this is right before they go to bed
what's their brain waves at this point
very suggestible
they're already dipping into Theta
they're an alpha they're in the love
stories because it helps them to imagine
and then I would say to them the same
thing every time you know
I really don't care what happened
what I care about is if you had another
opportunity in the same situation
how you would do it differently I just
want to know how we could evolve your
experience
and then of course they would give me
answers that were always Limited
you know especially my boys but you know
and I say yeah well if you do that you
know more than likely this is going to
happen did you think of that
no and then we go back and forth until
we had a very clear understanding of
what would be the higher road to take
the next time
and then I would say to them no
just so I'm sure that I understand this
can you repeat it back to me like whoops
that happened again what would you do
and then they would go and say it and
then fall off a little bit and I'd bring
them back and I'd review it with them
until the point where they could explain
it exactly what they would do are you
with me what did they just do
they mentally rehearsed it
yes or no
and they're installing the circuitry
they're priming their brain for the
experience I'm giving them tools
neurologically
are you with me still and I say to them
then if you did that then that more than
likely would create this experience and
how would you feel
and I would let them just contact that
feeling just for a minute and all I
wanted to do was combine an intention
and an emotion a new emotion you with me
then I'd get him in bed tuck him in and
I would tell him a story of these kids
that lived in a mystical land with
castles and dragons and princesses and
and then I would tell them the story of
these kids and then I would bring in
their story
into
the allegory because there's a story
allegory is a great way to associate
with characters
and then I would tell them the lessons
that they learned while I repeated it
back to them in a very creative story
and so many times they look at me just
before they fall asleep and they'd say
was that me
let's say I don't know was it
the next day I'd get them up of course
I'm up at you know before the sun come
on come on get up we got things to do
come on I connect with them I'd always
connect with them and let them know that
they're important and that they matter
and that I love them and I would tell
them how the day was going to go the
main things that I'm going to remind you
just so you have some structure and then
there's going to be time to play but we
have to get these things done I give I
just help them understand that there was
some ritual involved in this some
boundaries some intention
and then when we're at breakfast I'd say
what was it
that you would do if you had that same
situation with Paris again tell me
and then I would have them rehearse it
again and I would do it to the point
that they would say
well they wouldn't say that they'd say
God I just
want this thing to happen so you would
leave because you can just leave me
alone just I just can't wait for it to
happen so I can get on with my life rule
number eight change your environment I
believe that if you can get two out of
those three in order if there's physical
stress emotional stress and chemical
stress then there's got to be physical
balance chemical balance and emotional
balance so let's just say you take all
your vitamins you take your drugs you do
your Pilates you do your core power you
know you you know get massage
acupuncture Chiropractic you run you
know all the things but you're still in
a toxic environment where you're
responding and reacting to the same
conditions emotionally well your body is
going to stay in the past because the
emotion is keeping you connected to the
past so what happens then
this happens numerous times and and the
people that do come to our work the
chemo didn't work
the surgery didn't work the radiation
didn't work the vegan diet didn't work
the ketogenic diet didn't work the yoga
didn't work nothing was working and so
then this is a point where the person
says I nothing outside of me
is changing what's inside of me and we
just had a cancer researcher on the
stage with Stage fat at had stage four a
stage four sarcoma in her uterus that
metastasized everywhere there's no
evidence of her disease in her body any
longer now
do I do I appreciate medicine do I
appreciate appreciate pharmacology yes I
do and I think for for acute uh uh
health conditions that medicine has a
really great handle on acute and crisis
situations when it comes to Chronic
health conditions
chronic health conditions require a
lifestyle change period you got to make
different choices if you truly want to
do it so
100 years ago 75 years ago you got
diagnosed with a health condition you
went to the doctor and she said or he
said you need this organ takened out
taken out you need this type of
treatment and I'm the authority you have
no access to the information that I have
so just do what I tell you and
everybody's signed and informed consent
and if my gallbladder's not going to
take that out if my uterus isn't good
take that out to take out whatever you
want
so then fast forward to today you get a
diagnosis what happens now
people go oh goodness um thanks for the
diagnosis then they go home and they
research everything about the health
condition why because information is
available now through technology so they
go back to their doctor and they say
gosh you know I want to try this other
treatment I want to try this alternative
thing and the doctor either says I don't
know anything about that or that's trash
and the person now looks squarely at the
doctor and the eye and says time to find
a new doctor in other words people do
the best when they feel good about the
care the health care that they're
choosing right so they're taking their
power back now to be able to say maybe
there is another way so the pharmacology
that we use when were altered either
with anxiety or depression or cyclic
mood patterns or whatever it is is an
attempt to create chemical balance in
the body however if you're still
reacting to your ex in the same exact
way are you still
always predicting the worst thing that
could happen to you in your future and
embracing the emotion of that event
you're conditioning your body into
anxiety and you'll have a panic attack
and and and yes the the pharmacology
will help to create more balance but
your response and reaction to the
environment somehow
causes you to become dependent on that
exogenous substance now I don't have a
problem with that because everybody's at
their own point in evolution my mother
just listened to anything the doctor
said even when I said to her mom your
blood pressure is up because of stock
market crash she didn't want to hear
that she didn't think that she had to go
to the doctor for all these tests and
all this stuff and of course that's what
it turned out to be so
there's a greater listening that's
happening in the world now because of
information that that it's the four
minute mind that person that had the
sarcoma that stood on the stage was a
cancer researcher that told her story
that's the four minute mile I'm watching
1500 people in the audience leaning in
they're witnessing truth right in front
of them this is now they're conscious
that there's another possibility that
they were unconscious of and she doesn't
look vegan and she doesn't look slim and
she doesn't look young and buffed and
like a movie star she just looks like a
person a normal person and invariably
somebody in the audience
listening to truth because she's
speaking truth right now
telling her story about how hard it was
to overcome herself how hard it was to
overcome her body when she was in pain
and she didn't feel like doing the work
she did it anyway to overcome her doubt
to overcome her fear to overcome all of
those things and and believe in a future
that she can't see or experience with
her senses yet but truly understands the
science of how
that takes place once you understand the
what and why
the how becomes easier so we use science
as the Contemporary language to
demystify the process of personal change
and transformation it is the language
that we use that is that that doesn't
exclude anybody we don't talk tradition
we don't talk religion we don't talk
culture we don't talk spirituality
because that's going to divide the
audience so we create the scientific
model that's the first point learn it be
present with it but the next step is you
got to be able to teach it back so in
our audiences when we explain things and
we're combining quantum physics with
neuroscience and all neuroendocrinology
and all that stuff
once the person I finish the concept
you're gonna have to turn to Jonathan
and say okay let me just explain this
because I got a fire and wire this in my
brain I gotta understand what I'm doing
and why I'm doing it and nothing left to
conjecture nothing left to Superstition
nothing left the Dogma you understand
exactly what you're doing and why and
when you understand the meaning behind
it your prefrontal cortex turns on and
when it does the PowerHouse turns on and
you can get an ice bath and know nothing
about it the benefits of an ice bath get
an ice bath and you could really have a
really bad response you can get some
knowledge about what to do when you're
in the ice bath and the value of it and
once you understand that and you get in
the ice bath you will actually have
positive effects on your immune system
where when you didn't know what you were
doing and assigned meaning to it you had
a negative effect so so the person then
who's who has the intention
and the understanding and we set up the
conditions in the environment and we
give them numerous opportunities
to get Beyond themselves numerous
opportunities to practice and evolve
their experience our research shows that
if you do that for seven days
the number of metabolic changes
metabolites from the cell thousands of
metabolites that are being released in
the brain and body
suggests that the person is literally
their bodies believing they're living in
a different environment now here's the
weird part they're in a ballroom there's
nothing really amazing happening in a
ballroom I've been to thousands of
ballrooms they all look the same and yet
the body's looking like it's in a very
enriched environment it's looking like
it's in a different place so when you
have evidence and testimony
and you have evidence in scientific
measurements I think evidence all of a
sudden becomes the loudest voice and it
only takes one person or two people to
break that four minute mile and then all
of a sudden just like an infection
spreads amongst the community and
creates disease all of a sudden you see
health and wellness become as infectious
as disease there's a dramatic
transformation in biology so now that
that's possible now that people are
aware of that possibility
now it's in their Consciousness and
Consciousness is awareness and
information allows us to become aware of
what we were unaware of and that's what
that's that's what life is about to ex
to to evolve our experiences and and
some of those people are dependent on
Pharmaceuticals independent and I never
say stop taking anything
I'll say I always say keep going to your
doctor keep getting the scans keep
getting the tests you need feedback to
let you know what you're doing is
correct and and then make another choice
if it isn't but a lot of people actually
cross that River and wind up on the
other side and those are the people that
we're studying because those their blood
is Rich with a lot of information that
suggests that that there's a very
different experience going on inwardly
rule number nine learn Stress Management
the one thing that if it took you five
years
of living in chronic stress and living
and what are the emotions of stress and
survival aggression anger hatred
um competition judgment insecurity Envy
jealousy pain suffering guilt shame fear
anxiety depression hopelessness
powerlessness those are all derived from
the hormones of stress and psychology
calls the normal human States Of
Consciousness those are Altered States
Of Consciousness and so then
if you're living in emergency and your
response
to your co-worker to your boss to the
traffic to the news to whatever it is
weakens the organism and you're
switching on that emergency system over
time no organism can live in emergency
mode for an extended period of time
you're you're drawing from the body's
vital resources and you're converting
all of its energy into chemistry for
some threat real or imagined okay so
then if you keep doing that in chronic
conditions
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for long-term building
projects the immune system dials down
the digestive system becomes out of
phase hormones change
our cardiovascular system changes our
respiratory system changes this is
because the body is believing it's
living in a dangerous environment okay
so the problem then becomes that the
arousal of these stress hormones that
create fear that create anger aggression
or create pain
and give the body A Rush of energy
now people become
almost like an addict they they need the
problems in their life to reaffirm their
addiction to that arousal to that
emotion
and now if you can turn that response on
by thought Alone number one you become
addicted to your own thoughts and number
two you become addicted to the the very
life the life that you don't even like
yeah so then you ask the person why are
you this way and they'll say I am this
way because of this event that happened
to me five years ago well what that
really means is they had some really
profoundly emotional experience and the
stronger the emotion we feel the more
altered we feel inside of us the more we
pay attention to what causes it and the
brain freezes a frame and takes a
snapshot and that's called the long-term
memory and so then that person then is
altered biologically from that Trauma
from that event and what they don't know
is every time they remember the event
they're producing the same chemistry in
their brain and body as if the event was
occurring okay well then you tell the
person why are you this way well then
they'll tell the story
about how it happened and the research
on memory says that 50 of that story the
way you recounted is actually not
accurate it's actually not the truth
that people don't have the same brain so
they embellish the story to excuse
themselves from changing and if they
make it more difficult or they they add
more components to it then now they'll
reaffirm their identity in being a
certain way that story becomes very
important to them and they believe it
they behave it as it and they ultimately
become it and so then can you use those
same principles and begin to start to
manage your inner world
and by regulating taking time before you
start your day and say
okay before I grab my cell phone before
I get up and run through my routine you
know my automatic routine where people's
are on automatic pilot and in a
habituation of what they did yesterday
and their body's dragging them into the
same predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will to choose to become
conscious to a set of automatic programs
well if the familiar past is the known
and the predictable future is the known
there's only one place where the unknown
exists and that's the sweet spot of the
present moment so if you said okay let
me get present here let me remind myself
of those thoughts I don't want to think
let me remind myself
of the behaviors I want to change let me
review in my mind the emotions that
caused me to move to a lower denominator
let me become so conscious of that that
I won't go unconscious again let me
remind myself who I do want to be how I
do want to think how I do want to act
how I do want to feel and let me see if
I can get so good at doing this with my
eyes closed
when I start my day that I can do it
with my eyes open now this this this
River of change you know people say I
can't predict my future well the best
way to predict it is to create it not in
the known but in the unknown so our
research shows that if you teach a
person
to go a little further
than where they normally stop you know
when they get uncomfortable they they
quit and reach for their cell phone or
they say I'm busy got too much to do if
you get people present really and you
teach them how to stretch a little
further and they get beyond that known
and there's no danger there's no threat
there's no survival the body actually
begins to relax into the present moment
and when that happens we see this over
and over again energy moves right into
the heart and now the heart all of a
sudden starts to beat with more order
more coherence the autonomic nervous
system is no longer dysregulated from
stress it's starting to organize and
this feeling feels right right so then
if you can sustain that state
independent of the conditions in your
environment then you're mastering your
environment you're mastering your life
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is retire
your old personality if you keep firing
and wiring the same thoughts in your
mind that are related to complaining and
blaming and making excuses and feeling
sorry for yourself and judging other
people
um nerve cells that fire together wire
together you'll develop a very very
complex neurological Network that you
installed and keep doing it it becomes
so automatic it becomes unconscious
those thoughts for the most part are
slipping by people's awareness unnoticed
unchecked and every thought has a
chemical associated with it so
the moment the person begins to review
the problems in their life and those
problems are connected to certain people
and certain objects of certain
conditions at certain times and places
the moment they start thinking of their
problems they're thinking in the past
because the brain literally is a record
of the past and every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it so the moment they recall the problem
they feel the emotion of sadness or
guilt or shame or unworthiness now the
bodies in the past so then if you begin
to weigh the number of times
people unconsciously do that in their
waking day they may have the best
visualization meditation rehearsal in
the morning and start out with really
good intentions
but that's 45 minutes or half an hour
weighed against the other 16 or 15 hours
of their day where they're back to their
old self and so
the thinking positively is have no
effect on the body because it's it's a
small portion of what the person is
doing on a regular basis so the process
of change
there's an equal component of unlearning
there's an equal component of becoming
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
becoming aware of your automatic habits
and behaviors even how you speak and
sensing and noticing the emotions that
you feel that have become so familiar to
you on a regular basis
that it feels like you and the moment
you stop doing that you got to get ready
because it's gonna feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar it's not
going to feel like you anymore and many
people will go back to suffering and
complaining because at least they know
how they feel and they're back in the
known so so this is such an important
concept because
um this explains why people when they
they do the work and they don't notice
the results they get up from their
meditations
believing in their future less
instead of doing their meditations and
getting up and believing in their future
more right and so the reality is yes it
takes
equal amount of firing and wiring and
equal amount of emotional conditioning
to condition the body to the future but
you have to retire the personality of
the past and you got to stay so
conscious of your unconscious self that
you don't go unconscious
in your waking day and that's being in
that River of change and it takes a lot
of energy a lot of awareness to do it
I travel around the world and I have the
opportunity to talk to all kinds of
people and one of the things that
independent of people's beliefs
political beliefs religious beliefs
whatever there seems to be a Common
Thread that people feel like something's
not right
and I think when
um you get to a point where you realize
that no health care plan
no government no religion is going to
take care of you
uh then who is going to take care of you
and the answer is you right
so my interest is uh to give people the
tools uh and the understanding that they
could heal their body that they could
create a better life for themselves
that they could overcome past traumas
and scars that were created even as
early as childhood that tend to be
unconscious programs that keep them
repeating the same you know scenarios in
their life
uh to teach people how to induce
mystical experiences so that it changes
the frame of what the way they look at
reality
and so what an amazing time in history
to be alive because Consciousness is
awareness
and awareness is paying attention and
paying attention is noticing so so if a
person lives a life as an example
and is diagnosed with a health condition
they're what they're conscious of
is just a certain number of choices that
they could make based on the past based
on tradition based on what's worked for
normal or natural
but what happens when that person has
done the chemotherapy has done the
surgery has done the radiation has done
the vegan diet has done the gluten-free
diet has done the ketogenic diet has
done all the things all the exercise
and they still have the same health
condition
yeah it begs the question you know if
our personality creates our personal
reality
and our personality is made of how we
think how we act and how we feel
then the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life not their ex not their
parents not their culture they create
their life so the fundamental question
is if if
if I want to change my life
then that means that I have to change or
nothing changes in my life until I
change right so the person who's done
all these treatments and still faced
with a health condition this is just an
example
all of a sudden says there's got to be
another way there's got to be something
else and so knowledge information
when we learn knowledge we learn
information we make new Connections in
our brain that's what learning is we're
forging synaptic connections
but that philosophical theoretical
intellectual information is void of
experience
someone who takes that knowledge and
applies it and personalizes demonstrates
it initiates that knowledge
is now interested in the truth of the
experience of that information
so the person then who becomes conscious
that they could actually heal themselves
by changing the way they think the way
they act the way they feel if I truly go
into the experiment of no longer
thinking the same way no longer acting
the same way no longer feeling the same
way and I start thinking about what
thoughts I do want to fire and wire in
my brain
and if I do it with intention and
attention I'll begin to install
neurological Hardware keep doing it and
becomes like a software program it
becomes a new voice in your head that
goes from I can't to I can
no magic there if you said how would
greatness live today how what would love
look like today what would be a greater
expression of myself in the things that
I do
turns out if you close your eyes and you
rehearse in your mind
how you're going to be
in any aspect of your day if you're
truly present the brain doesn't know the
difference between the inward experience
of what you're imagining and the outer
real experience that look the brain
looks like you've already done it the
brain looks like it's already
experiencing now do that enough times
the hardware becomes a software program
and you start behaving like a different
person super athletes do this this is
musicians athletes dancers everybody
who's good at something is always
rehearsing in their mind
that that rehearsal is just as important
as the physical demonstration it's
priming the brain because the brain is a
record of the past now you're actually
making it a map to the Future you're
installing circuits to use
if you said God I live my whole life in
guilt I didn't know it was guilt uh in
shame or unworthiness unself-doubt and
security fear and all of a sudden you're
looking at that emotion you understand
that emotion is actually down regulating
genes and creating disease you figured
that out you read about it makes sense
then all of the hatred all the anger all
the bitterness you have to someone or
something in your past
is keeping you connected to the past so
you'd say
can I teach my body emotionally what a
new future could feel like before it
happens not waiting for your wealth to
feel abundance or waiting for your
relationship to feel love or waiting for
your healing to feel gratitude that's
the old model of reality of cause and
effect this is about causing an effect
turns out if you can elevate your
emotional state
and you can sustain that emotional state
your body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating that
emotion
and that emotion that you're creating by
thought alone your body's actually
believing it's living in a new reality
in new environments now the environment
signals the gene the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion that person is actually
signaling genes ahead of the environment
genes make proteins and proteins are
responsible for the structure and
function of the body the expression of
proteins is the expression of life okay
every day the person practices going
from the old self to the new cell this
is what's happening in the world right
now
as they start to change and they start
unfiring and unwiring and they stop
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past and practice this
they emerge as a new personality they
become somebody else and like magic
the diseases exists in the old person
and there's somebody else now here's
where Consciousness comes in
that person comes to a workshop and they
stand on the stage in front of 1500
people and they tell their story
and everybody in that audience is
leaning in
why because they're looking at truth
they're looking at the exam who just got
healed from a chronic uh chronic because
I'm talking about stage four cancers I'm
talking about Parkinson's disease I'm
talking about rare genetic disorders
and now the person in the audience is
becoming conscious
of a possibility that they were once
unconscious to And when they see that's
possible it's a four minute mile I mean
four minute mile nobody thought anybody
could break a mile and underperformance
they said it was biological artificial
yeah physiologically impossible 1400
people have done it already so like this
is the four minute mile someone's
piercing through a limitation the level
of unconsciousness and now that's a
footprint in the quantum field but in
three-dimensional reality you're looking
at that person they look no different
than anybody else and the person says
if that person can do it I can do it as
well if you give people sound
information
and then they can repeat that
information
they're wiring it in their brain
they're creating a new model of
understanding
if you show them how to apply that
information
if they do it properly they will have
some type of transformation
that transformation isn't something that
causes people to feel bad or unworthy it
causes them to open their hearts
it causes them to feel Joy
to feel gratitude they feel differently
and if you're able to then create that
elevated emotion and you teach people
more information they will continue to
transform themselves and that's called
Evolution if you think the same thoughts
the same thoughts always lead to the
same choices the same choices lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same feelings
and you're now caught in your old self
but new thoughts should lead to new
choices and new choices should lead to
new Behaviors new behaviors should
create new experiences and new
experiences should create new emotions
and that should Inspire evolution
we say that your personality creates
your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
we could say that your personality is
your state of being
so now geniuses
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
keep demonstrating the same behaviors
keep living by the same feelings and
emotions your personal reality is going
to stay exactly the same
but if you have new thoughts
that lead to new choices that
demonstrate new actions that create new
experiences that cause you to feel
differently you will begin to walk into
a new future how many people understand
this
so most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work you literally have
to become someone else
so crossing the river of change going
from the old self to the new self
requires you stepping into the unknown
and if you are now in the unknown and
you feel uncomfortable because you're
leaving guilt behind
you leave unworthiness behind you see
the biggest problem with most people
is they want to create wealth but they
feel lack
they want a new life but they feel
unworthy
that's Mind and Body in opposition
and our research shows that you can
teach people how to recondition their
body to a new mind
and when that occurs they begin to
create very powerful things in their
life would you say it's smart to focus
on one goal I mean if you're sick
obviously it's it's smart to focus on
only getting healthy but if you have a
regular life and you say you know I
would like to have the classical stuff
more money more wealth more love more
joy would you say in those meditations
it's smart to focus on different goals
or should it rather be the Big Goal like
a big Vision I have for my life that all
the steps on the way are just
marks I will pass at one point well
let's answer that on two levels too
because people come to our workshops for
all different reasons some people come
because they're sick some people come
because they want more money some people
want more a new job a new opportunity a
new career a new relationship some
people want the mystical the people come
for all kinds of reasons to me I don't
care
what I care about is that they latch on
to a vision
and they learn how to create whatever
drives them to that elegant moment where
they're so present and so passionate
about what they want and they have a
clear intention a Clear Vision a
coherent brain
and they have an elevated emotion
combined with it that they create hard
coherence and now they're broadcasting a
whole new energy into the field and
whatever we broadcast into the field
is our experiment with Destiny
so I want people
to know the how because we have plenty
of people that have made millions and
millions of dollars that were living in
the back seat of their car or filed
bankruptcy we have plenty people that
were stage four cancers serious health
conditions that are healed but really
people think they come for those reasons
but we come for wholeness that's why we
come that when we feel so whole and so
happy with ourselves so connected to
something greater
if you feel wholeness
it's impossible for you to want
how can you want when you're whole when
you're whole you feel like you have
everything
so
I want people
to reach that point where
they feel so whole uh that they no
longer want and that's when the magic
happens teaching them that
allows them to understand that when they
come back to their senses they open
their eyes
they're not looking
for the experience they feel like it's
already happened and if you feel like
it's already happened why would you be
looking for it then
if your body is conditioned emotionally
into that future
um you're not separate from the energy
of your future you're connected from it
to it but the moment you get in traffic
and you start getting angry you get on
the line at the bank and you start
getting impatient or you're sitting in a
staff meeting you start judging A
co-worker
you just disconnected from the energy of
the future and now you're back to the
energy of your past and you've done
nothing wrong
you just lost your connection to the
Future now now the importance of that is
to notice that you're disconnected and
if you say to me well that person made
me feel this way and think this way I'd
say oh my gosh you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim in
your life the victim is saying that
someone or something is controlling how
I think can feel
but a person who's producing outcomes in
their life all of a sudden they say wow
the way I'm thinking and feeling is
creating outcomes in my life
now I'm a creator of my life and now I
believe less and I'm a victim of my life
our immune system is kind of like our
rudimentary nervous system it has cells
that are mobile and they're called
plasma cells or white blood cells and
their job is an internal defense in many
of our bodies plasma cells line the
mucous membranes got the digestive tract
uh all the orifices of the body the nose
the mouth ears and it's a line of
defense against foreign Invaders and
toxins and when the immune system is
facing some foreign Invader whether it
be a virus a bacteria a mold a fungus
some foreign agent it is the army of
plasma cells that move towards the
danger and begin to attack these foreign
agents and
there are cells in your immune system
called t cells and T cells are like the
ninjas of the immune system they release
very powerful chemicals that can
denature and break down any foreign
Invader and T cells have these little
trumpets that stick out on the receptor
site so picture this big circular
spherical glob and you have all these
different receptors and these T cell
receptors are these long trumpet
appendages and when they come up to a
virus or they come up to a bacteria when
they come up to even a cancer cell
they notice there is a foreign agent and
immediately this T Cell receptor
attaches to that foreign agent and
begins to release a lot of unhealthy
chemicals that begin to cause that
foreign agent to to die and then
memorizes that foreign agent and passes
the information on to the army of the
rest of the white blood cells in the
body and and this is a strong immune
system and when plasma cells and white
blood cells
begin to function well they release
chemicals called immunoglobulins and
immunoglobulins are proteins that are in
the shape of a y and those y-shaped
proteins are antibodies and what they do
is when the the white blood cell
releases an antibody it begins to block
The receptors of the foreign agent
that's trying to attack the white blood
cells so when a healthy immunoglobulin
is released it suppresses the the
Warfare the the cell receptors that are
trying to attack the white blood cell
and now you have a strong defense you
have a strong immune system and your
body right now is doing that in fact
your body is always evaluating all those
foreign agents whether it's a virus a
bacteria or even a cancer cell
and it's working to keep the body in
balance and the immune system a strong
healthy immune system does that
constantly always behind the scenes of
your awareness we have such compelling
evidence in science with brain scans you
can make your brain work better you can
make your heart work better you can make
your immune system work better you can
make your cells go from really sick to
really healthy we've got great evidence
you can become immune to Serious viruses
you can be immune to the bacteria we've
got the measurements if you can lengthen
your life
we have great evidence and people aren't
monks they're not they're not nuns
they're not religious Scholars they're
just common people and then we have
testimony
of people who are the example of Truth
they are they are the example of truth I
would rather have dinner with those
people than anybody anybody else they
know something right
so evidence then becomes the loudest
voice right and and that's what I think
what people are looking for right now
the truth is so lost in sensationalism
and the truth is so lost in emotional
agreement and so people who want to feel
fear
they program themselves and accept
believe and surrender that people who
want to be hate be hateful
it's all there it's all there and it's a
it's a matrix to find the way out right
and and I think I think there's a door I
just I just think that we have to trust
the innate information that that comes
from within us in order to create a new
future
to change something in your life nothing
changes
in your life until you change that's uh
that's the story right so then the
question is okay is in order for me to
create something new I'm going to have
to combine a clear intention that's a
function of the brain and the mind
that's a a process that you can get
better at and you got to combine that
with an elevated emotion and that means
then you can't wait for your healing to
feel grateful you can't wait for your
new relationship to feel love you can't
wait for your uh um
wealth to feel abundance you know that's
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in fact
we're going to teach people actually how
to feel the emotion before it happens
and when you combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion
that's going to require your heart to
move into balance and move into order it
turns out that's a skill too that you
can practice
so then when you combine those two
elements so that clear intention with
the elevated emotion and you can sustain
that for a period of time
the coherence in the brain the coherence
and the Heart actually act like a Wi-Fi
signal you're starting to put out a
Broadband spectrum of frequency and
energy that causes you to feel connected
to something and now you're no longer
trying to get something done or waiting
for something in your outer World to
Change to take away the emptiness or
lack you're feeling because you don't
have the experience yet if people can
actually feel the feelings of the
emotions before the experience happens
they wouldn't be looking for it because
they would feel like it already happened
right so they teach people how to
sustain these states and if they can
the side effect of that is that you
start seeing synchronicities in your
life those serendipities those
coincidences those opportunities that
you're no longer going anywhere to get
them and you're not trying to control
the outcome or Force the outcome or
fight for the outcome or predict the
outcome or compete for it that's that's
when we're matter trying to change
matter when you synchronize your energy
to a possibility in your life and you
start seeing those synchronicities in
your life now when you start seeing
those opportunities occurring you're
going to start paying attention to what
you've been doing and do more of it and
you go then from being the victim of
your life to being the creator of your
life and the cool part about it is you
don't have to go anywhere to get it
somehow out of nowhere it seems to come
to you and those moments are moments of
Awakening so the formula really is about
combining quantum physics with
Neuroscience with neuroendocrinology
with psychonur Immunology with
electromagnetism epigenetics all of
these different branches of science to
build a model to show people that you
actually can be the creator of your life
people that were traumatized from
childhood that were abused sexually
physically emotionally that were
suicidal that had all kinds of health
conditions they came to the edge of that
emotion that kept them connected to the
past and they were ready to give up in
one meditation because
they they never had felt an emotion like
this that they could remember that it
was so intense
and they thought about all the times for
the last year that they never missed a
day of doing a meditation even when they
didn't feel like it or when they wanted
to quit halfway through and they didn't
they went all the way they thought about
all those times
that they went to that point and they
went one more time really and their
words are always the same and my heart
blew wide open and I looked back at my
entire past and I don't want to change
one thing in my past because it brought
me to this present moment and I can see
my betrayers I could see the people in
my life that had a hand in this and I
have nothing but compassion for them
because now the person is no longer
viewing that past from the same level of
Consciousness they're viewing it from a
place of Love of wholeness and they see
the greater good of all of it and now
they're they're they're
conditions their health conditions their
endometriosis their uterine tumors I
mean whatever it is literally
goes disappears and they have an
incredible incredible change in their
brain chemistry they're in love with
life they're off their meds uh they're
not suicidal they're why would they be
they're free so it could happen in an
instant when the heart is healed and
everybody gets the new signal the body's
out of the past the body's no longer
feeling the emotions of the past and
sometimes
we got to come right up against that
edge that's yeah that's the great moment
if you have a very brain driven person
like myself
and in some parts I disconnected from my
emotions just to protect me in regular
life
um and it's a challenge for me to
reconnect to my old emotions that I
already had in circumstances that would
help
um do you have any advice
yeah well uh God I have a lot of advice
around that because
um
uh seventy percent of the time that
people in their waking lives uh they
live in a very protective State they
live in a state of stress or in a state
of survival in fact it's such a program
that we don't know that we're doing this
we're always
spanning the environment to determine if
it's safe or not and if something
appears out of the predictable or
unknown it alerts us and we move into a
state of arousal and we begin to turn on
the very systems that begin to say
danger threat possible scenario that's
not safe
and when that happens we literally begin
to anticipate an outcome
and when we do that we're always
preparing
for what could go wrong
and we begin to create the emotions
ahead of the experience of what happens
if it goes wrong whether it's fear
anxiety worry sadness pain when we do
that unconsciously that's what a program
is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide and show a certain
amount of success and be competitive
then you're not going to open your heart
it's not a time to do that it's a time
to survive and thrive in an environment
and yet
um in our work I see men that if they
practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering being free
being allowing yourself to let go I
think the ego is something that is
healthy when it's in Balance like if I
have a bonfire in my backyard and those
and the Flames are getting a little bit
too big and there's ashes and sparks
flying off the bonfire your ego says
David step back you know it's it's
preservational wants to take care of the
body if we're hiking on a cliff and we
come to a very narrow path and it's a
thousand foot drop your ego is going to
say stay close to the wall don't go out
to the edge you could be injured and be
heard so the egos has a function to
really in a sense be analytical and and
weigh what we know against what we don't
know and it's healthy the problem is is
when it's driven by the hormones of
stress and stress is when your body's
knocked out of balance it's not that
knocked out of order that state actually
causes you to be altered and there'll
always be a gap between the way things
appear or the way you appear and the way
things really are you're in an altered
state now for the short term that's
great all organisms can tolerate that
but if you keep doing that for an
extended period of time the arousal
that's created from the stress hormones
actually causes the analytical mind all
of a sudden to go into overdrive so now
the endorsement of the ego becomes
enhanced and we become selfish that's
what it does it causes it causes us to
be self-indulgent to be self-centered to
be self-important be self-apprandizing
to be full of self-pity because in
stress there's only one thing that's
important when you're in survival and
that's you and so all of our attention
goes on our body all of our attention
goes on all the elements in our
environment and we come become very
preoccupied with time now
when we're in balance
and there's order in the autonomic
nervous system there's health
and if stress is when you move out of
balance autonomic dysregulation then you
are altered from wholeness you were you
are separate from uh everyone and
everything in your life and you tend to
trust less it's not a time to open your
heart in the jungle the survival Gene is
switched on you don't communicate very
well you're looking at how you can get
to where you need to be or accomplish
what you need to do first and you got to
be there first and compete because this
is all driven by those stress hormones
so the ego becomes out of balance now
here's the cool part about all of this
when people are driven by those stress
hormones and they don't know how to
change it they don't know how to
self-regulate again it's not that you
react the question is how long are you
going to react if they don't know how to
do that
the problem with most people is they
start analyzing their life
within the emotion that's disturbing
them now emotions are a record of the
past so what we see on brain scans over
and over again when you start over
analyzing and overthinking in a selfish
way
100 of the time you'll make your brain
worse and that will have dramatic
effects on your body so when the heart
is racing because it's pumping blood but
you're sitting in a zoom call and you're
smiling and you're looking at that
person a zoom call and you're thinking
about ways to murder them you're
producing those chemicals but you're not
running and you're not fighting and
you're not hiding so what happens is the
heart is pumping against a very closed
system and it moves out of order it
moves out of balance and now the
autonomic nervous system which controls
and coordinates all other systems in
your body
is out of balance and that dysregulation
causes disease so then the fundamental
question is okay can I trade fear can I
trade anger can I trade competition can
I trade frustration resentment in
patience hostility uh hopelessness
powerlessness Whatever anxiety for an
elevated emotion can I learn how to
dial down those stress hormones and
practice feeling elevated emotions turns
out
you can do that now the real question is
when you're in your heart you're not so
selfish in fact when there's a change in
blood flow to the heart and oxytocin and
nitric oxide is released you tend to
want to give you you tend to want to
consider the whole now you lead with
your heart
you're not separate from anybody you're
you're functioning as a community so I
think then that
um our future as as human beings is that
we have to be able to live in an
elevated state in our hearts and if we
fall from grace back into those survival
emotions the key is to be able to
self-regulate and get so good at it in
your meditation with your eyes closed so
good at it that you can do it with your
eyes open now that's when the game
becomes really really important so uh
when people do the work and they do
their meditations and they come up
against themselves gosh I want them to I
want them to come up against their fear
and in the in the week-long workshops I
want them to come up against their
impatience I want all those thoughts
that come up that say I can't it's too
hard I'll never change it's my ex's
fault it's my boss's fault I want those
thoughts to be right in their face and I
want to give them tools to let them know
that right on the other side of that
that thought right on the other side of
that propensity to want to get up and
quit right on the other side of that
emotion that's keeping them connected to
the past if they're willing to sit in
the fire
to sit with themselves and instead of
getting up and quitting on themselves
learn how to self-regulate and create
brain and heart coherence I guarantee
you every time they go a little further
and they produce those victories of
those victories add up so what's the
side effect of that you return back to
your life you don't need jerk as much
why because you just overcame some part
of your aggression and anger by sitting
with your body and like training an
animal
training a dog I don't know training the
servant to be present to to to to to to
be greater than the body as the mind to
execute a will that's greater than those
unconscious programs and what we found
out is when people actually apply some
type of formula to be able to do this
every time they bring the body back into
the present moment it starts liberating
energy
so there it goes the frustration there
goes the impatience and all of a sudden
the unknown which tends to be such a
scary place for most people is the
present moment you see the side effect
of that as the person's more present
they're less preoccupied with all the
things that people spend most of their
attention on now so you overcome the ego
you overcome the personality uh uh
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
that you've got to be able to lay it
down
and as you temper your body and your
mind
um the ego tends to be less selfish and
more selfless and then the side effect
of that is that then if I say hey look
at David he's actually doing it I'm
gonna try it too because he's he's doing
it and research and Neuroscience says
you hang out with people that do things
you start your brain synchronizes and
you start doing those same things it's
called an emergence emergence that's the
birds all moving in the same direction
it's a school of fish moving is one mind
and one heart if you study that you
think there's one leader like that
everybody's following a leader like a
top-down phenomenon it's actually wrong
it's a bottom-up phenomenon everybody's
leading so the way we change the world
then is that you work on yourself I'll
work on myself we get to show up and
bring our best and when we're not at our
best we excuse ourselves get back to
that state and we present ourselves back
to the world and I think this is such a
great time in history where people
really need some tools to be able to
cope with with all all the challenges in
the world we may not be able to control
everything in our outer world right but
we certainly can control our inner world
and so it's not so important to not
react I mean everybody reacts I react
the question is
how long are you going to react
so if you keep an emotional reaction
going on for an extended period of time
you're memorizing that emotion and your
body as the unconscious mind is
believing it's living in the same past
experience 24 hours a day seven days a
week 365 days a year the body doesn't
know the difference between the real
experience that produces the emotion and
emotion that we create by thought alone
so then the emotion then reaffirms the
state and then people start to use the
problems and the conditions in their
life to keep that emotion going and I
would call that an addiction so we
become addicted to the very life we
don't even like
so
it's important then for people to
realize then when you have that moment
where you have crisis or something
breaks down that you do have control
over it and it's a formula and it's a
skill and our research shows that you
can teach people how to do that and so
then when you're living by some emotion
there'll always be a gap between the way
things appear and the way things really
are emotions alter our perception and if
you act during that time you'll always
say the same thing I should have never
said that I should have never done that
I should never thought that I should
have never sent that email so then
shortening your emotional reactions
is a level of intelligence then that
causes you then to recalibrate because
most people don't think they have
control over that they'll say that
person did it to me that circumstance is
the reason I am this way then I would
say if something in your outer
environment
is controlling your thoughts and
feelings then you're a victim to your
environment and yet
how you think and feel creates your
outer world so if you're thinking and
feeling equal to everything that's known
in your present personal reality you
keep creating more of the same so to
change then is to think and feel greater
than the conditions in your environment
and to be able to do that to such a
degree then you're no longer reacting to
the same people in the same way and that
takes an effort it's and it's not easy
in the beginning but once you start
practicing
uh you get better at it and just like
anything else you start to move through
your life with more coherence and you're
less likely to knee-jerk and if you're
less likely to knee jerk then you're not
in an unconscious program I think one of
the most important things when we lose
sight of our vision is to make time for
ourselves and I think that when you
invest in yourself you invest in your
future
disconnecting from people in your life
and places that you have to go and
things that you do or things that you
own long enough to begin to reignite a
vision of how you see yourself or how
you see your future and begin to
emotionally Embrace that future and
change your state of being allows us to
see a whole new landscape if you've lost
sight of your vision take a moment and
remember that vision and begin to
emotionally embrace it and from that
state of being start to think about the
things you want to do the choices you
want to mix write them down review the
behaviors that you have to demonstrate
your goals and experiences and how it's
going to feel when you do that enough
times you're changing your brain
neurologically and you're changing your
body genetically write down the
unconscious thoughts that you have to
stay conscious of become aware of the
choices that you no longer need to make
review the behaviors and habits you have
to change about yourself and become so
conscious of them that you won't go
unconscious at all during your day
remember the experiences in your
environment that you need to stay away
from whether it's a person or a thing
just for a period of time
so that you can keep that Vision alive
and most importantly review those
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and become so conscious of them and
name them when you feel that feeling
that if it's guilt or sadness or pain
the moment you start feeling it and you
become conscious of it that's when you
can begin to change and if you keep
doing this over and over again the
unlearning and the relearning the
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self is going to cause
you to arrive at a whole new future and
when you do this could become your new
habit we're all faced with
uh
great challenges brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations and there's
always a door there is always a door
and so
your personality creates your personal
reality it's that simple and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life which
means if you're going to change
something in your personal reality
in your life you got to change your
personality you have to change nothing
changes
until you change that's the bottom line
you change but you the thought of
changing my personality seems so like
but I like who I am kind of but I'm also
cranky I'm also annoyed so like who is
that person underneath all of these
ailments I guess all of these but it's a
weird thing to say you change your
personality
well look I mean there's many things
that I love about my personality just
like you do I'm gonna take that with me
but there are things if I'm going to be
defined by a vision of the future
they're things that can't come because
the moment you say I want to have a
mystical experience where I transcend
this three-dimensional world and and you
want to have a really profound moment a
transcendental moment you start showing
up for that and it doesn't happen right
away then one you're gonna start
disbelieving you start Stop Believing
yourself so so the moment we're defined
by a vision of the future that's bigger
than us that vision of the future is not
the vision of the past and when we do
that we take away we take with us our
discipline we take our concentration we
take our
presence we take our passion we take our
strengths with us all those things you
take but the things that are standing in
the way are those old beliefs are things
that stand in a way that that that that
stop you from connecting to it those are
the things you come up against and and
it's not the it's not the mystical
experience of the transcendental
experience it's who you become it's not
your wealth it's not your health it's
who you become it's not your freedom
it's who you become in the process and
it's the overcoming process that we
overcome that we overcome that we
overcome that we overcome till we
finally become and so many great people
in history you know even wealthy people
people always want to be wealthy but if
you study wealthy people that really did
it they failed miserably thousands of
times until they figured it out and so
you keep showing up for yourself enough
times
You're Gonna Change you're going to
change you're going to be thinking
differently you're going to be acting
differently you're going to be feeling
differently and that's when the universe
starts to conspire in ways that we just
never even thought about that's that's
that's the beauty behind creation when a
person begins to slow their brain waves
down they have to go when you're in
stress when you're in survival you
narrow your focus on a cause that's
called a what's called a convergent
Focus so now you're blessing the energy
centers of the body they're under the
control of the autonomic nervous system
and when the autonomic nervous system
moves out of balance the brain moves out
of balance right we now are focus on the
cause and it causes each one of these
different energy centers
to move into incoherence as well and
those little little individual brains
start moving into incoherence and send
an incoherent message to the cells and
tissues and organs hormones then become
down regulated and the body starts
moving out of balance
so when we bless the energy centers
where we reprogram these energy centers
two things has to happen
they have to be able to slow their brain
waves down they have to get out of that
high beta State and the way we do it is
to go from a narrow Focus to a broad
focus when you open your focus when you
open your awareness that's what creates
coherence in the brain because you're
going against that habit
putting your attention on matter
so there's a convergent Focus which is
focusing on matter and then there's a
Divergent Focus which is focusing on
energy while reality is both particle
and wave matter and energy so if a
person can slow their brain waves down
from beta brain waves to Alpha brain
waves now they're starting to fall out
of their thinking brain right into the
home of the autonomic nervous system
okay the person can't change their brain
waves it'll never work because they're
in their neocortex in their thinking
mind right so that's one thing that has
to happen the second thing that has to
happen is that they have to practice
both a convergent focus and a Divergent
Focus now by the convergent you're
focusing on let's say I'm going to focus
on this energy center right and then you
move your focus to another energy well
first you first you focus on that energy
center that's particle and then you
focus on the space around it that's wave
and so when you open your awareness and
you're able to do that and you're in
your autonomic nervous system you can
put an intention there which will create
more balance and estrogen more balance
and your your sexual organs you move to
your second Center you put your
attention there that's your where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy so now you're beginning to
Direct Energy yeah into that Center but
now you become aware of the space around
it why to create coherence and that
little brain send the coherent message
to the cells and tissues go to your
third center right in the pit of your
gut well there's a huge Celiac plexus
there solar plexus a lot of connections
in there so now put your big one that's
a big always getting a lot of signs
there yeah here and here part and solar
plexus yeah that's those are big ones
and you tune into that energy then you
put your attention in your heart it has
its own individual brain yeah and when
you make energy here when energy finally
arrives here guess where it goes
automatically straight up we've measured
it so now once you start opening your
heart you've got more energy in your
heart you get more energy in your brain
got it show it on time just go straight
to the heart that's why we do it that's
exactly why we that's why we open the
heart so it creates a field and it
begins to drive energy to the brain so
now that energy is going to cause the
person
to have a different Consciousness a
different thought pattern right and now
they're going to be thinking possibility
because in survival the first three ones
are all about survival yeah it's really
not a creative process of creating from
mind it's more about a more primitive
you know
um
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
gland so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers and they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they get into the operating system they
can Master convergent and Divergent
Focus they're no longer living just this
way they've practiced opening their
awareness and focus on energy becoming
conscious of it and as these brains
become more coherent and they start
producing different signals to hormones
and chemicals and into different glands
in the body that's what's being
upregulated to make different different
Expressions I want to show you what it
looks like
when you learn something new you have a
hundred billion neurons in your brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections if you took
and you stacked
stack five thousand miles high that's
the distance from Los Angeles to London
if you took a scoop of gray matter the
size of a grain of sand you would have a
hundred thousand neurons in it with over
a billion connections now
I'll stop right after this slide
learning is making new synaptic
connections every time you learn
something new this is what's happening
in your brain geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today your brain did this
boom that's learning
physical evidence as a result of your
interaction in the environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place and learning is making new
connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint if
learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts over and over again you're
going to wire them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them
and all of a sudden they develop a
long-term relationship and just like any
relationship the more you communicate
the more they connect and neurons are
exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves into
networks or what's called neural
networks and neural networks are just
gangs of neurons that have fired and
wired together to form a community of
neurosynaptic connections that's related
to a thought a skill a habit a behavior
a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic your personality creates your
personal reality and your personality is
made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this little video has created the
present personal reality called your
life
which means then if you wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life you
would have to change your personality
that means you'd have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it it means you'd have to
become aware of your unconscious habits
and behaviors and modify them
and you'd have to look at certain
emotions that keep you connected to
experiences in the past and decide do
these emotions belong in your future
the beauty behind this is is that when
you begin to change how you think how
you act and how you feel you should
begin to see changes in your life and I
recommend that you try it out you can't
go to the Future holding on to the
biology of your past decide what
thoughts you can bring to your future
write them down thoughts like I can it's
too hard I'll never change I'll start
tomorrow what's wrong with me it's
someone else's fault thank you
decide on what behaviors or actions or
unconscious habits you have to change
how do you talk do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses do you feel
sorry for yourself just becomes so
conscious of those behaviors that you'll
never go unconscious again and lastly
you have to decide what emotions no
longer belong in your future that means
if you want to be wealthy you can't take
lack if you want to be healthy you can't
take insecurity or fear you got to begin
to condition your body to a new mind if
you do this
every single day your personality
creates your personal reality and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel change any
one of those things and you change your
life and begin to measure the effects of
you it cause give it a shot if you think
about gratitude when when you receive
something favorable or you just receive
something favorable if something's
happening to you or something just
happened to you that you are excited
about you feel grateful so the emotional
signature of gratitude means that it's
already happened or something wonderful
is happening to you now the body is so
objective
that it does not know the difference
between a real life experience that's
creating that emotion and that emotion
that you're fabricating by thought alone
so the body's believing it's living in
an environmental condition that's
favorable to you
and we only accept believe and surrender
to thoughts that are equal to our
emotional state so in the state of
gratitude your body is more prone to be
programmed through its autonomic nervous
system into a different Destiny and the
research that we've done uh in our in
our on our research team shows that just
four days of feeling gratitude
can strengthen your immune system by 50
percent by releasing a an immunoglobulin
called immunoglobulona which is their
body's primary defense against bacteria
and viruses is better than any flu shot
and it's the body's natural capacity so
so when we trade
anger and frustration and fear and
anxiety and pain and suffering and guilt
for an elevated emotion the autonomic
nervous system starts to regulate back
into homeostasis imbalance and of course
stress is when the autonomic nervous
system is knocked out of homeostasis
imbalance it's dysregulation so we teach
people how to give thanks for the things
that they create in their life actually
before it happens and when we do that
properly
we start to see measurable changes in
the person's body and measurable changes
in their energy and ultimately
measurable changes in their life so the
concept of presence is such an important
concept because I think that paying
attention is being present and it's a
skill just like anything else the more
you practice it the better you get at it
and I think we know when people are
present with us in our lives is because
they're paying attention to us and we
know when they're not present with us
because they're not paying attention
well where you place your attention is
where you place your energy bottom line
so if you're thinking about what's going
to happen in the next moment or what's
going to happen in a day or you're
reviewing what's something that happened
three days ago you're placing your
attention in some future scenario or
some past memory and we siphon energy
out of the present moment and we don't
have available energy then to really
begin to create an outcome in our lives
but if we're truly present and we're
relaxed and poised in the present moment
if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy then you
have a lot of energy in the present
moment to execute a lot of energy in the
present moment to make decisions the
more you do this the more you experience
those moments of flow the
synchronicities the serendipities the
opportunities the coincidences because
there's a lot of power in the present
moment so one of the key elements in the
creative process is teaching people how
to relax into the present moment so if a
person is thinking about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and objects and things
at certain times and places the moment
they think about their problems say
first thing in the morning when they
wake up if you believe your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
and your brain is a record of the past
the moment you remember your problems
you're thinking in the past and because
every problem has an emotion Associated
because you experience it the moment you
feel unhappy now your body's in the past
so thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so most
people
unconsciously start their day
with their entire state of being
biologically in the past and again the
body's so objective it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience uh and the emotion that
you're creating by thought alone so that
past that familiar past is called the
known and if you wake up in the morning
and you start thinking about
the predictable future and the people
you have to see and the places you have
to go and the things you have to do in
your routine predictable life
the same exact thing happens you're
you're imagining that future scenario
that's already known to you
and you're anticipating the feeling of
that outcome
so that becomes the predictable future
becomes the known as well so if the
familiar past is the known and the
predictable future is the known there's
only one place where the unknown exists
and that's the sweet spot of the
generous present moment in teaching
people how to create from the present
moment is what begins to produce the
magic and the changes that take place in
their lives
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there then I'm gonna
feel so great now that well then they're
back to the program waiting for it to
happen for them to feel the emotion
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no